oficialmente turquía se ha retirado hoy
de la convención de estambul un tratado
internacional para para prevenir la
violencia contra las mujeres y la
violencia machista el mismo presidente
turco recep tayip erdogán lo ha
defendido hoy mismo en una conferencia
en la que ha hablado de esta retirada
como algo positivo dice él para turquía
porque turquía va a crear su propia
convención para defender a sus propias
mujeres ha dicho el presente turco recep
tayyp erdogán sin embargo muchas a
muchos colectivos feministas aseguran
que esta retirada será un daño terrible
para los millones de turcas que vienen
al país porque las va a dejar mucho
menos protegidas delante de sus maridos
hermanos a amigos y novios que las
asesinan en una media de una persona a
una mujer al día en turquía
cada día una mujer muere a manos de su
marido o novio por eso mismo en turquía
y en todo el país en estambul también se
están celebrando ahora mismo dentro de
unos pocos minutos manifestaciones
multitudinarias de mujeres que dicen no
a esta retirada